if you're feeling the love for lovecraft
country here are five other titles
definitely worth checking out on this
week's binge guide
the first season of hbo's road trip
horror fantasy loved craft country
is a hit with fans and critics already
coming in
certified fresh this show was created by
misha green
and produced by jordan peele and jj
abrams and blends the terrifying
monsters of hp lovecraft's universe with
the horrors of racism in segregated
1950s america
and expanding on those themes this binge
guide includes the more classic literary
monsters
the unknown tares of traveling and much
more starting with our certified fresh
pick
penny dreadful this frightening
psychological thriller ran for three
fresh seasons on showtime
and brings a unique take on classic
horror origin stories like dr
frankenstein
and dracula starring ava greene josh
hartnett and timothy dalton
critics praised this show for being
skillfully shot and superbly acted
while utilizing a vast array of
fascinating characters and locales
to tell a unique story along with
binging this one you should check out
the certified fresh
first season of the spin-off show penny
dreadful city of angels with a binge
time of about 37
hours altogether our audience pick this
week is the wgn drama
underground with an average audience
score of 90
this show tells the epic escape story of
the underground railroad and comes from
lovecraft country creator
misha green and stars lovecraft's
journey smolette
underground ran for two fresh seasons
and also features names like aldous
hodge and christopher maloney
critics say it blends credible terror
with enough compelling thrills to
overcome the storyline's
occasional cliches this is a must watch
for fans of lovecraft country
especially those who have about 14 hours
of binge time to spare
for our throwback pick this week we want
you to sink your teeth into hbo's
true blood debuting back in 2008 this
hit drama series ran for seven seasons
five of them fresh and stars anna paquin
as a telepathic waitress in a near
future who meets a vampire
it was created by alan ball who also
gave us another hit hbo show in six feet
under
and critics praise it for the graphic
thrills steamy romance
and biting satire get it it was biting
it'll take you about 74 hours to watch
this whole series
and in the interest of making one more
vampire pun
it definitely won't suck coming in with
our under the radar pick is the 2019
documentary
hard noir a history of black film
using interviews with a who's who of
black horror cinema both past and
present the film explores the history of
black horror and the role of african
americans in the genre
critics say this dock more than lives up
to its title offering a smart and
entertaining overview
of american film history through an
overlooked lens
it will only take up 83 minutes of your
binge time but you'll no doubt pick up a
few other titles and creators worth
checking into
afterward and finally our editor's pick
this week is the fantasy drama series
american gods
this stars show centers around a war
that's brewing between old gods and new
as it follows an ex-con working as a
bodyguard for a powerful old deity
who is on a cross-country mission to
reclaim his lost glory
critics initially loved the show's
bombastic style with visual riches that
are matched by its narrative impact
but after a change in showrunners and a
couple characters after season one
season two wasn't as well received but
it was renewed for season 3
so while you wait for that you can
decide for yourself by benching the
first 16 episodes
in just about 16 hours ok hopefully this
will improve your trip to bingecraft
country be sure to comment and let us
know what you're currently streaming
and check back here often for more
recommendations based on the shows you
love
on the rotten tomatoes binge guide
[Music]
you